never too early for christmas toy
shopping and we have an exclusive reveal
only on cbs mornings meet the newest
historical american girl doll her name
is claudy wells here's her backstory
she's come on behind you claudia grew up
in new york city's harlem neighborhood
in the 1920s now that era became known
as the harlem renaissance a time of
cultural and artistic growth within the
local black community as the story goes
nine-year-old claudi was surrounded by
plenty of talented people writers
painters singers but she didn't know
what she had to offer so she's on a
mission to figure it out in honor of the
release american girl is donating 100
000 to support the harlem school for the
arts and lucky for us we have claudia
right here in studio
it's very cool yeah
now you may be wondering how many
academics does it take to accurately
depict a harlem renaissance american
girl doll and the answer is five
apparently they had five academic
consultants to get the look right to get
the story the backstory right to get the
box right like the details really matter
can we look in here
these dolls are so popular i didn't
realize how popular they were oh no it's
huge parents go crazy for these things
but online people are especially excited
about
this doll look at that
ladies and gentlemen little trinkets
little trinkets little hat box action
i don't i don't i shudder to think what
the price may be i've been in an
american girl doll store before and i
did not get out unscathed
financially speaking